c'est à dire si c'est long une deux ou
trois mètres de sa caméra il a déjà très
mal à l'aise
il s'exprime pas alice retourne vite
quand ils voyagent ils demandent sont
ventilés voyage dans l'avion avec son
dentier il recommence en pologne puis il
déménage il revient à son dentiste en
france il vit dans son honneur
tout ce qui fait autobiographique même
quand c'est absolument napster comme à
ses débuts
deux filles s'est installé à la campagne
je pense uniquement pour ne pas être
trop éloigné de sa caméra même la nuit
il ya nous sommes au pied de tombant
d'animation est ce que tu peux nous
expliquer comment tu travailles
c'est très simple voilier à la caméra il
y à la table et c'est tout d'ailleurs le
principe des lames de l'animation est
très simple aussi c'est une succession
d'imagés une sorte de synthèse de
la réalité que tu crées que tu modifies
à chaque photo suivante d'ailleurs cette
nécessité des modifications
c'est une particularité de l'animation
de films d'animation c'est un critère si
tu veux parler par exemple doute les
arts graphiques
tu ne peut utiliser que celle qui se
prête à cette modification
évidemment ça limite mais ça te donne
une possibilité supplémentaire
le mouvement et annaba